hello and welcome to the new world
reveal source for everything anime and
manga and today we are here to dive into
a very juicy topic regarding hunt hunter
as we examine some of the greatest
controversies in
and around the series because everyone
loves controversy and nothing is immune
from controversy and to be clear the
definition of controversy is a prolonged
public disagreement or heated discussion
unfortunately as such this means that
practically all internet discourse can
technically be considered controversy
because that's just how it works we
can't be having pleasant discussions on
the internet
no no no but i have been quite picky in
selecting our topics here today though
just as i know that you are all quite
picky in selecting whether or not you
will subscribe to the new world review
which
will result in regular hunt on content
being uploaded straight into youtube
feed and i know you have high standards
but together
you and me and that button i know we can
meet them so please do comment down
below if you are a new member and i
welcome you
but we are going to hop all aboard the
controversy train with a fairly recent
one and it is the
sensationalist accusation that huria oku
the author of gantz has some kind of
grand fuse with yoshiro togashi the
author of hunthunter and that oku even
hates hunter hunter ugh the monster but
i say sensationalist because headlines
like these really do not help convey any
form of you know what's the word
i think truth that's the one truth
because on the 23rd of february 2020
oku seemingly unprovoked decided to vent
a little on the old twitter never a
great idea but the target of this
venting was apparently togashi and oku's
message
read as follows when i was a young manga
artist someone other than my regular
editor came to pick up my pages one
evening he just kept talking about how
amazing yuyu hakusho is i said
i don't know it at all and he ended up
talking until the morning about how
great what's his face togashi is i
wanted to say
why don't you go tell this togashi
himself i don't
know him man i know huyasu takatogashi
is though and hence ever since every now
and then on the internet you will hear
that hiroya oku hates togashi and
hunter hunter which he did not even
mention he singled out tagashi's
previous series you haka show and it's
not anything close to what he said
regardless as far as i care to interpret
it this seems like a very natural human
response whenever someone beat a friend
or a colleague
or just a stranger tells you that you
have to watch or you have to read
something the most common internal reply
is going to be
get f'd i will decide what i watch and
when and when that person keeps harping
on
and on and on about the thing you just
start to hate it for no reason other
than this person won't shut up about it
so this whole thing is definitely blown
out of proportion there is no beef
between oku and togashi
it's just that at some stage in his
young career oka got tired of hearing
about tagashi although why he would
choose to post this now
or then i guess in 2020 when it would
have occurred years and years and years
ago i mean when yoo hakusho was being
published actually
well that's a long time ago so that's an
interesting thought as to why you had
posted now but i suppose there may still
be some
residual resentment either towards
togashi the editor
or both speaking of tagashi though this
man is far from immune from controversy
ever
ever so far he may be the author of
hunter hunter but simultaneously he is
probably one of if not the most singular
hated individuals i hunt onto fans and i
have to say being a hunt hunt fan can be
very conflicting at times and of course
we all know that this is because of the
impossibly long hiatuses that the series
frequently takes in fact at the time of
this recording we are in a hiatus right
now
not just any hiatus though we are in the
longest hiatus in the history of hunt
hunter publication there has not been a
new chapter published since december
2018. i will repeat that number 2018.
so it's been well over two years of no
content but this isn't the first
extended hiatus the fans have endured
it's not even the second or the third
but in reality it's probably like the
fifth mega hiatus that this series has
gone on and this always divides hunter
hunter fans into two categories hence
controversy one is that togashi is lazy
and doesn't care about the series
anymore and this then leads into a quite
profound hatred of tagashi himself
because of what i suppose we'll call the
feeling of betrayal you know the idea
that he's just abandoned this story his
fans and
and we don't like that do we on the flip
side though the togashi defenders also
come out in full force usually
empathetically identifying with his very
legitimate medical issues and creative
burnout or simply taking the approach
that togashi doesn't owe you the fans
anything
this is his series and he can do
whatever he wants with it and whenever
he wants to do it
and if that means not finishing it then
i'm gonna version so look i read
something else
and personally i kind of flip back and
forth in the middle of these two views i
mean i do believe that an artist has
complete right to their own work and if
you like that work that's great but
it's not yours on the other hand i do
also think it's a dick move to leave
your doting audience just
perpetually hanging because let's just
explore this let's say the reason why
you can't publish chapters is because of
medical issues that's fine tagashi khan
control we all understand that so what
we could do in this situation is hire
another artist to draw the story i'm
sure that the publishing company
shueisha would pay for that artist in a
heartbeat because new hunt hunt content
is basically just a license to print
money it turned shueisha into a mint
however reportedly togashi doesn't do
that because of his desire to retain
control of hunter hunter himself he has
a pretty terrible track record of
working with assistants and he does want
to do
most things on his own which i suppose
is why we're in this situation he won't
allow anyone to finish hunt hunt for him
even if it's just the art under his
story directive which you can say is
selfish
and that's also fine like i said i will
defend an artist's right to maintain
impetus over their work but from the
perspective of fans it sucks
it really really sucks and i don't think
that everyone should or even needs to be
understanding about this issue tagashi
is being selfish to a degree but that's
his right and fans have every right to
be upset about that and thus the issue
of hiatus
ex-hiatus will stretch on into all
eternity to continue though let's do a
controversy that's actually based in the
series itself we're going to take a
rather
well known in practice controversy here
by delving into the volatile
topic of gender specifically this time
around the gender of one nephipito now
hunter is a series where tagashi has
never been afraid to stray away from the
binary view of gender all of which very
much culminates in this character here
nefapito who was designed to be
deliberately ambiguous and androgynous
as such in videos i always refer to pito
as they because saying he
or she is quite frankly incorrect
however whenever i do say
they i am inevitably met with a flood of
comments from people
mostly insisting that pito is female and
should be referred to as a she
and look i'm gonna be honest here i
suspect that most of these comments are
from people who you know may or may not
have had a bit of a wank
thinking about pito and may not want to
confront the reality of exactly what
they've done
let's start with an obvious indicator
though the name nephibito like the rest
of the royal guard takes their name from
an egyptian god nephitem as well as a
character from a french children's book
named pito the god being male and the
character being female thus immediately
sending us into this non-binary realm
there are of course conflicting pieces
of evidence within extended media of
course as the hunter hunter battle
collection does blatantly refer to pito
as female whilst the hunt hunter data
book would imply the opposite and refers
to pito as male in terms of the dubbed
anime pito is also usually referred to
as he by the other chimera ants
although the anime does notably depict
pito as more feminine than the manga
where pito often takes on more masculine
aesthetics but not
exclusively and it does change depending
on the time i mean the chimera antarctic
took like seven years to draw so all the
characters do change shape over
that term quite a bit but all of this is
to say that there is
no answer togashi very purposely created
nephipito to exist outside of binary
gender but as with all things gender
related this will no doubt continue to
be a lingering controversy within the
fanbase along with many other hunt hunt
characters such as alaka but we'll save
that discussion for another time having
brought up pito at this stage i'd be
remiss
not to mention the living controversy
that is the entire chimera antarctic
itself i'm not sure if i've ever
encountered a story arc in anime or
manga that has been quite as divisive as
this
and for good reason i suppose all of
this singular arc spans about a quarter
of the entire series and takes us on a
grand tangent of characters and ideas
many of which go on to ask some of the
biggest questions of
life the universe and everything that's
not really what hunter hunter was prior
to this though and the chimera antarctic
can be quite off-putting as a result
in my first watch through i found it
quite difficult to get into during the
early stages because the pacing was
slowed significantly and in addition to
that the roles of our main protagonists
were quite minimized and just in general
there was never an end in sight
retrospectively my opinion is
entirely different and both re-reading
and re-watching the series comes with a
lot of added value
like most of hunter hunter really
however the sheer bitterness i can
encounter whenever the word ant is
brought up is kind of shocking i now
have countless anecdotal examples of
people who have just dropped the series
during this part which is a shame
because i do think it ultimately ends up
being one of if not the best arc in the
series but at the same time i also can't
necessarily blame the person who dropped
it there this is where togashi's
storytelling evolved to a place of
unfamiliarity and while that unknown can
be quite exciting to some it can be a
huge gamble for others who may have
started watching hunter hunter because
they wanted to see oh i don't know a
plucky young boy on his funny quest to
find his father in this weird wacky
world
so it is a shock to the system and while
i think anyone who would call themself a
hunter hunter fan either managed to
overcome or embrace that shift
general anime fans can be quite a bit
different and this arc can become
quite controversial and you know who
else is controversial hisoka and not
just his general character either but
his voice actor daisuke namikoa he's a
bit of a scandal beacon i suppose making
him quite perfect for the role and
namikawa is actually a prolific presence
in anime
which is why when news broke that he'd
been having an affair with an employee
at his agency for three years well this
was pretty big stuff in japan
however the bigger issue may have been
that this employee may have been
significantly younger than him like
we're talking teenager level young not
that that really matters in japan they
have a much lower legal age of consent
but this did make for some quite big
news
and yeah look admittedly not really a
hunter hunter controversy i guess but
hisoka in general does
fit this bill quite nicely i'm sure that
at this stage none of us can remember
the amount of times that we've had the
conversation of
is hisoka a pedophile it's one of the
first things that my wife grappled with
upon meeting him in her review series
montante and it always comes up
inevitably when i meet new hunt hunter
fans
and i definitely lean on the side of nah
but hisoka is walking a very dangerous
tightrope in this series like the
talented circus performer he is and i do
genuinely know people who didn't even
make it to the chimera antarc in order
to drop a series because they dropped it
in response to hisoka
something i don't think i'll ever
understand because he's one of the most
compelling characters in all of media
and i'm honestly not sure if i would
have pushed through hunter hunter the
beginning stages without him but i guess
the raging erection in response to a
young child is maybe just a bit too much
for some and as for another controversy
here's one that most people should be
familiar with and its name is
gait more specifically the changes that
were made to kite story during the 2011
anime to this day this is probably one
of the most
complained about aspects of that
adaptation which is otherwise
pretty damn stellar but a decision was
made to emit kite's appearance in
chapter 1 of the series his story with
gone is cut from the first episode for
pacing reasons as well as the idea that
they weren't sure if they would even get
to adapt and cut story during the
chimera and talk so they did you know
the thing where you kick the can down
the road and just hope you don't come
across it again but you will because you
foolishly kicked the can
in the direction that you were walking
so when we did finally reach that can
again it presented a pretty massive
problem because gone needed to have this
immediate connection with a character
that the anime audience had never seen
or even heard of for manga readers this
was like a long-awaited reunion sort of
like if shanks and luffy were to have
median in one piece which i guess they
kind of did that one time but luffy was
unconscious
doesn't matter hunter hunter now but
because the anime had not ceded kite in
episode 1 what resulted was this very
clunky
sort of flashback sequence that didn't
tell the whole story
and had a bit of a retcon kind of feel
as if the anime were trying to rewrite
gone's past in front of our eyes
simply in order to insert this guy thing
and margaritas were and still
are pretty furious or at least a little
bit miffed as margaritas often are
because
this is what we do and anime watches
well they just kind of had to live with
this weird character who would end up
becoming the emotional core
of gone's entire character arc which
eventually culminated in his removal
from the series
kite is pretty important and to this day
yeah anime watchers will tell me that
they missed nothing with 2011 kite but
the problem is
if you've missed out on something you
probably don't know what it is you're
missing out on because you missed it so
how could you know so of course you'd
just say that all as well
because that's the only experience you
know and you liked it
enough i guess sadly though this aspect
of kite is undeniably poorly handled
yeah it did get the information and some
of the emotion across but nowhere near
what it should have been able to do and
as such this is yet another source of
delicious
hunter hunter controversy but what do
you guys think please leave your
thoughts in the comments below or even
join my discord server and if you're
keen for some more hunt on content then
please do go and check out some of my
other videos or even subscribe to the
channel for regular yes regular hunt
under glory delivered straight into your
youtube feed but for now this has been
the new world review
and i'll see you next time